في معركة
منطقة دونباس الشرقية بأوكرانيا ، يخسر الأوكرانيون
الأرض
ببطء ، ويستمر الروس في قصف
مدينة ليزي تشانسك ، مما يجعلهم يهربون
لأولئك الذين لا يزالون صعبًا للغاية أو
حتى مستحيلًا في
أقصى الغرب للبحث عن الجثث في
مركز تسوق مدمر في كريمن تشاك
يبدو ميؤوسًا منه بنفس القدر حيث يضع الناس
الزهور لأولئك الذين تم العثور عليهم ميتين وأولئك
الذين قد لا يتم العثور عليهم على الإطلاق ،
لكن أوكرانيا يمكن أن تدعي انتصارًا واحدًا على
جزيرة الأفعى ، النتوء الصخري في
البحر الأسود بالقرب من أوديسا عاد الآن إلى
السيطرة الأوكرانية بفضل هجوم مدفعي بين عشية وضحاها.
أجبرت المحتلين
الروس على الفرار ، أدرك الروس حقًا أنه
يتعين عليهم فعل الشيء الصحيح
وجمعوا أغراضهم وخرجوا
بمجرد أن يتمكنوا
من إطلاق الجيش الأوكراني هذا
الفيديو الذي يظهر الضربات الأخيرة في
حملته التي استمرت لأسابيع لاستعادة
الجزيرة الجديدة.  تظهر صور الأقمار الصناعية
ندوب الحرب التي خلفتها
روسيا ، لكن روسيا لم تزعم أنها انسحبت من
البؤرة الاستيطانية  كبادرة حسن نية تجاه أوكرانيا ،
سيمنع هذا الحل كييف من
التكهن بأزمة غذائية وشيكة
بسبب عدم القدرة على تصدير الحبوب
بسبب سيطرة روسيا الكاملة على
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من البحر الأسود
ردًا على
ذلك ، غرد وزير الخارجية الأوكراني بأن الروس
دائمًا ما يقللون من شأنهم.  هزائم بهذه الطريقة
لا ينبغي للشركاء أن يحذروا من
تزويد أوكرانيا بمزيد من الأسلحة الثقيلة حتى
نحرر المزيد من أراضينا.
حصلت على هذا الرد
[موسيقى]
منذ ذلك الحين
تم تخليد هذا الرد الجريء في طابع بريدي
أعيد طبعه على كل نوع من الهدايا التذكارية
وما زال مصدر فخر وطني
لن نتخلى عنه أبدًا كما لم
تعرفه أبدًا مثل الناس من
مثل  جزيرة الثعابين كانوا يعلمون أن هذا
يشبه القتال الذي لا يمكنهم الفوز فيه بشكل صحيح لكنهم
ما زالوا كما لو
أنه سيكون رائعًا إذا ر
سوف تكون إيماءة حسن النية الروسية التالية هي أن بوتين يطلق النار على
نفسه في مخبأه
سكوت مكلين سي إن كييف أوكرانيا